I'm waving it fast
[Applause]
[Music]
overdue Doctor Who review and it is time
to get into series for proper but before
we do just a quick word to let you know
that this review is sponsored by the
radio versus the Martians podcast Mike
Gillis and Casey Dorn and a revolving
door of guests come and talk about all
sorts of geeky things from ghostbusters
to comic books to wrestling to Batman to
the ova of one Arnold Schwarzenegger
it's always fun it's always informative
it is frequently funny radio versus the
Martians radio versus the marshes calm
or wherever you get your podcasts so let
us talk about the reintroduction of
Donna Noble into Doctor Who with
partners in crime so I make no bones
about the fact that Donna is my favorite
companion like I'm not gonna hold that
as like a rule bring this up later on
there's like no like know that going in
Donna's my favorite companion so there's
gonna be a fair amount of stuff where
I'm just gonna kind of gush about her
which is interesting because if you
watched my hum runaway bride review
she's integrating in that one which I do
think kind of works that you know we and
should we met her that way there was a
gap of time which we get a little bit of
information on here and then she's kind
of in a different place by the time this
starts up which I do think overall works
that said it doesn't make her actual
appearance in runaway bride any less
grading it just makes the journey for
the character work ultimately but that's
that was still painful episode to go
back for this I don't find particularly
painful except for a couple of moments
which I will bring up and
and I will mention but it's great seeing
it's great seeing her just sort of
aching for something more you really get
that like especially when she's talking
with will Fuu and also will tha's back I
didn't really talk about wealth in the
previous review you know when I was
talking about voyage of the Damned
because like I had so much other stuff I
want to talk about he's just kind of
there for a bit and while he's cute in
that I didn't fall in love with wolf
until scenes like this where he's
talking with Donna he looks at her and
he gets her like he gets that she's
disaffected in a way that her mother
absolutely does not and not that her
mother is cruel but her mother just
doesn't get it
and her her grandfather does wolf does
get it and he's so sweet and so kind and
the two of them together is is fantastic
so I like that Donna is just kind of
looking into things that she thinks will
eventually cause her to run into the
doctor again I do think that the kind of
almost running into each other not quite
running into each other thing that
they've got going and like the first
half of the episode I think that's
pretty fun and pretty well done a little
cheesy perhaps but like that's the kind
of cheesy I can roll with the kind of
cheesy that's actually hard for me and
as a painful moment is the extended
pantomime seek who pant mind charade
thing where they're like thing you know
between the doors and I just I don't
love that moment I never have just it's
not my style of humor and I feel like in
a lot of ways they they felt obligated
to do it just because that kind of
comedy is in Katherine Tate's wheelhouse
which is my acknowledgement that yes
it's done well it's just not a kind of
comedy that I like especially given that
it kind of drags on and just keeps going
for a bit I do like the way it ends
though and of course once the two are
paired together I love their report
Donna's retaining a little bit of that
sort of harshness for lack of a better
term from
of the runaway bride but she has an
eagerness to to get to do the this again
that is undercutting that and softening
it just enough which is good they're not
at their full banter rapport yet but
there are early hints of it like when
the two of them are confronting Miss
Foster and you know they've got a little
bit of back-and-forth I'm like oh there
it is that's the stuff I love that as
far as the story itself goes you know
outside of the reuniting of these two
characters it's it's functional it works
is kind of a weird little alien scheme
I'm kind of thing the idea of the living
fad is really weird but I can roll with
it I can dig it also in terms of upping
the danger of it because like initially
you're like this seems like a win-win
you foster your kids and and you know
these people lose weight it's Andi the
doctor even kind of acknowledges that
like no seems like a good system but
because you know she is willing to
sacrifice people as she's not supposed
to be doing in the first place although
that was weird like this hearing like
the doctor has invoked the shadow
Proclamation before but it's there's
something about the doctor quoting you
know chapter and verse of galactic law
that throws me off I think a lot of it
just has to depend on who he's doing it
to so like if he's confronting somebody
that you would think will they care
about the law okay fine that's fair
enough but with someone like Miss Foster
who is clearly you know brazenly going
against what she should be doing for him
to stand there and like to literally
just say you know this is a this is
against galactic law I'm like that's not
the argument to be making she killed
somebody like that i i'm fine with the
doctor taking a moral stance it's weird
to me when the basis of his morals
is the letter of the law when I always
have felt that the doctor is a much more
a spirit of the law kind of person he's
not gonna let somebody stop doing
something because well technically
that's not illegal so I'll just go away
then like whether or not it's illegal
like I don't I don't think you really
should be on his radar at all is it
wrong yes it's wrong is it illegal
who cares it's wrong and I I'm harping
on this a little bit but um like this
happens during this kind of this tail
and stretch of tenon I know part of it
is to remind us that the shadow is to
cede the term shadow Proclamation a few
more times before we actually see them
at the end of the season so I like I
understand part of it is that but I
don't know it's just it's just a weird
thing for me that I don't totally like
another thing that I'm is a little weird
this is something that I rarely have
complaints about but the music as much
as I love Donna and as much as I'm not
even gonna say it's not fitting for her
I don't like Donna's theme music you
know the dee dee dee dee dee dee dee
like I just I don't like it oh yeah I
never have it reminds me of like Robin
Williams oh this is a fun little zine
kind of like like II walk music or Jar
Jar Binks music like it reminds me of
that and it's annoying especially
because it's tied to a character who I
love so much and again it's not even
that the music doesn't work I just don't
like it like my ears kind of just yeah
ah don't enjoy that this also this isn't
actually a complaint but it's something
that I kind of get a kick out of is it
like or a written rule somewhere that
villains who are clammy I have a
clandestine operation need to sneakily
drop in hints to
they're really doing in their legitimate
business because miss foster foster
mother adipose it's also the name of the
alien species the fat just walks away
it's like yeah I could almost see like a
like an evil boardroom going what do we
do for a tagline for this thing that's
really that's not actually helping
people lose weight but instead is
turning the the fat into something
living that then wanders off
we'll have it say the fat just walks
away just a room full of board room full
of people like like guy a big cigar yeah
yeah I don't know strikes me is like as
weird that that kind of thing is so
prolific like not even in Doctor Who but
like all over the place it's always like
you learn what these companies are
really up to and suddenly it's like they
put it in the name wait why did they do
that not even really a complaint it was
just something that struck me while
watching this the reporter actually
works as a decent red herring because we
find out that because the the Miss
foster or matric affiliate however you
prefer um she is like oh it's her she's
the problem you're looking at a monitor
and we you assume it's not and we find
out it's the reporters and that's kind
of a cool little mislead I also like
that that the doctor frees her says you
bet you might want to run instead the
reporter sticks around starts rifling
through files and then turns around and
there's the villains again and they're
like tire up it's like oh you gotta be
kidding me
I did I enjoyed that moment a fair
amount as well oh haha I've mentioned
this before but I get to mention again
what do I pay Treon supporters is in
this episode so the the scene that takes
place in the in the sort of restaurant
that that Donna's mother is visiting a
friend and there's there's a there's a
couple they look like they're on a first
date or something kind of in the back
they get like two
shots the guy purple shirt that's Nick
Nick is a supporter of my patreon and I
love that fact and that has nothing to
do with anything but I love it so much
it makes me very very happy
and it gives me an opportunity here to
add an additional mention of the patreon
so I guess it's also self-serving and
all of that you know subtle I ain't but
coming back to the episode the the
resolution on the matron that that
worked decently for me I do like that
the doctor you know while he was
certainly gonna turn her over to the
authorities I'm sure which I get like
let me be clear I don't have a problem
with him turning people over to the
authorities either it's just like him
invoking that the fact that it's
breaking a law that makes it wrong I
don't know I'd get off that but I like
that he is you know just telling you
look just come on this this situation is
not gonna end well for you
it's he it's to a degree that we
actually haven't seen from Tennant
as much as you'd think when it comes to
the villain of the story because Tennant
established in his very first story you
know no second chances he is a I gave
you a chance you decide to do this now
you will pay for that kind of person so
the fact that like he knows that she's
in danger and is trying to save her life
I actually kind of like it's one of the
softer moments for Tennant and I don't
think he gets a lot of notice I think he
largely because more often than not he
kind of does the he more often than not
his standard response would have been oh
she's in big trouble then just kind of
kick kick back and let what was gonna
happen happen um I kind of like that he
doesn't hear and I like to I'd like to
chargon think that you know partially
that's that's Donna already starting to
influence him which we'll see a little
bit more even in the episode after this
I think that was all the stuff I wanted
to hit
yeah like the if I remove the the
reunion of Donna and and the doctor then
the episode is just okay but you put
that back in on Mike no I enjoy this
because I love these two together so
much partners in crime you seen it what
did you think about it
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about a whole bunch stuff to do I
mentioned the patreon supporting that
I'm get you a look at the docket for the
upcoming month you get to voting polls
on subjects there's the discord you can
get your name in the credits all sorts
of rewards are involved so check that
out plus down there you'll find merch
you'll find links to my other social
media all sorts of things you can click
on give it a look or don't you I'd
appreciate it but you also don't have to
because at the end of the day folks
you're the council I'm just running the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]